watching John Wickford you know what it
made me miss as you know I realized it's
kind of like three yeah
funnily enough not John Wick three
uh I don't know has it is it just me or
has there just been a decline of you
know old school martial arts kind of
like films right because it's hard
what do you mean this like it's hard to
train for that like Keanu Reeves was
trained for [__] like decades and
doing that stuff yeah I think that it's
just it just doesn't look nearly as good
as John work well yeah of course yeah of
course I'm not just like talking about
John Wick because Keanu Reeves did train
the [__] out of that
um he made a [__] Banger film I know
I'm like this is me nitpicking John Wick
forward none of none of these criticisms
actually matter I'm gonna have caveats
but
um
yeah it made me realize that the last
like the last real martial arts movie I
watched was probably the raid the ray
two right and that was how many [__]
years ago now I remember back in the day
yeah I remember back yeah that was
it felt it felt like such a long time
ago you haven't seen it but you know
back in the day there are so many
different martial arts flicks coming out
but there hasn't been just a rising star
of just a martial arts film you know
main character like you know we had
Bruce Lee Jackie Chan Donnie Yen you
know I mean I feel those are very hard
names to live up to right yeah yeah but
that's the thing they're Legends
um Jet Li as well there's the the there
used to be just so many right and so
many different martial arts films being
made and there just doesn't seem to be
any coming out right now it's it's like
swings around abouts right it's like you
know you get you get uh every now and
then you'll get like a fantasy period
where everyone's fantasy and they'll be
superheroes and then I'll be space and
then I think it'll come back around I
think it's just not it's just not I
don't think yeah I don't think people
are really that interested in martial
arts right now unfortunately and in a
broader scope so you think a lot of
people like who are really into that
kind of stuff are like I would rather
watch UFC or something actually it's
funny you mentioned that because I was
talking to this with digest he was like
yeah UFC has just killed martial arts
films I'm like I don't know if that's
true because a little bit I think
because there's always that there's
always a discussion like who would win
the Fire Bruce Lee or Donnie Yen you
know what I mean and then Joe Rogan
comes along and he's just like well uh
yeah
I've done more BMT so it's uh highly
likely that the frogs are gay
scientifically uh you bring a MMA
fighter in there he he wipes forward
both of them it's been proven every time
you you you bring an MMA fighter to a
Kung Fu Master and the MMA fighter wins
every time I do think there's a little
bit of Truth in that way like I think a
lot of the gym I don't know maybe I
don't know like I think it's more I
don't know I I also don't I felt that
yeah there are not many good movies
coming out martial arts movies and I
also just don't really care about it
much right now I'm kind of like yeah
whatever I mean I watching John Wick I
was like that's basically a martial arts
movie hidden in underneath that is a
martial arts movie where guns are the
martial arts yeah right what do you call
like gun Jutsu or something uh gun
cutter they called it something they had
like an on-term yes it was gun cutter
which
no I can't remember uh but it came from
I believe equilibrium the film with
Christian Bale oh yeah uh that's where
the term kind of originated from and you
know a great movie where they kind of
made cool looking things I I've looked
way too deeply into this because I'm
like I [__] love martial arts films
so I'm like where did this come from and
you know there there was this fake
martial arts uh in equilibrium where it
was like it was meant to make it so that
you are you the way you move and the way
you are angled is makes you less likely
to be hit by bullets while also
optimizing how you can fire a gun would
you think about it for a second and I'm
like that's [__] [__] but also
you see some of the scenes in
equilibrium I mean like I don't care
that that's [__] that's awesome Epic
yeah that's [__] epic yeah but when I
watch UFC I'm like when I've seen it I'm
like I actually just don't want to see
two dudes nearly kill each other I think
I'm okay yeah I see it enough on Twitter
so I think that part of my like medieval
bloodline kind of just let a few I'm
civilized now yeah I just kind of I'm
sure there was a time when we had
nothing better to do as a civilization
where that I kind of got something out
of that but like boxing I I've seen and
I kind of weirdly my brain I'm like this
feels a little bit better even though
she's people giving each other brain
damage yeah watching UFC I'm like this
is a little too much for me I'm like
these people look like they're actually
like being killed sometimes I'm like ah
I mean they they definitely run into the
trouble of that yeah I'm like a risk um
I'm okay like this is just like not not
it for me yeah yeah I'll go back to
watch it I'm just gonna play Street
Fighter yeah
maybe I'm maybe I'm a beta male I don't
know I'm just like I just don't get joy
out of seem to beat the [__] out of each
other yeah yeah I've been on Twitter
enough yeah honestly yeah you see it on
Twitter every day I mean I you know I do
find some uh you know some sometimes I
see a UFC clip and I'm like damn that's
[__] bad absolutely like athletes and
they're amazing what they do but for me
it's just like I don't I'm good yeah the
compilation of like you know like level
1000 IQ moves why UFC plays it's like
like you know that stuff is like all
right yeah that's kind of sick yeah you
know when they like flip accidentally or
you know like any cool thing like that
but just a regular match I'm just like
like one I'm not really invested and two
I don't want to see people getting hurt
I saw this clip the other day and it I
don't know why it came up on my thing
but it was a UFC fighter who was having
like an asthma attack and he was like
get my inhaler get my inhaler and it's
like mid-fight and then the guy asked
him like is it okay he's like yeah it's
FDA approved and he takes it and then
afterwards I guess the guy I think his
name is Dana White or something he's
like he's like yeah so I actually uh he
wasn't allowed to take that that's
actually an illegal substance you
absolutely cannot take anything in the
octopus and I was like yeah because
technically counts as steroids right I I
don't know what it is I'm like do you
have an asthma attack man what do you
want to die like I I don't think he was
he was trying to get an edge I think he
was just trying to breathe bro I don't
think there was any any like like
adrenaline in there yeah I'm always just
trying to live yeah to me I'm like do we
really need a sport where if a dude's
having an asthma attack we have to be
like absolutely not he needs to suffer
it's like ah I'm good I'm good I'm
having kidney failure Health it's like
sorry you're in the Octagon kind of
can't do anything about that yeah yeah
yeah you want to start the match if you
want to get traded yeah I mean like
boxing fights right like if you're
getting beaten the [__] up they just
call it right they're like stop the
fight yeah yeah and you see it's like oh
you don't get to stop the facts you're
dead
you've already been knocked out because
of how violent the sport is yeah like
it's like I'm like I'm good like and I
get it if you're into it I'm totally
fine with that I think there's literally
just a me personally thing I yeah it's
too much for me yeah yeah like you
sometimes you see Knockouts and you hear
that you something you hear you
I thought that to me is just like God
damn oh God damn I heard that from here
man his ancestors [__] felt that God
damn yeah I know who are into UFC I feel
like they're a little too much into UFC
you know what I mean I don't know they
talk about it I have never met a UFC fan
I've had some friends who are into it
and they're like a little too into it
I'm like what are you why are you so
invested in this yeah I I know I know
quite a few people into UFC as well
really
um someone's a little too invested in
seeing someone like beating the [__] out
like two beating each other up I'm like
I'm like it's a little I know I think
there is no because I I think there is
there there is that caveman part oh for
sure yeah but from what I found the
people that are really into UFC as well
there's there's that but there's also
like you know there's there's two
different ways to view a game right
there's the haha who won haha it's
football go like ball go in the gold
goal post haha we cheer and then you get
to like the deeper level where you start
appreciating it as like an art form just
like oh there are the meta there's the
metagame there's the tactics they're
involved in this and for the people I've
known that are into UFC they most of
them are also doing martial arts as well
yeah they're doing some form of Martial
that makes sense you know so there is an
appreciation on just the art form as
well and then you get to see someone
knocked out you're like yo let's go oh
God damn my balls are expanding
from the amount of testosterone yeah
I don't appreciate it oh you're a league
player
that's true and a balloon's terror and a
balloon
please Hollywood whatever Hollywood or
Asian Cinema give me more action films
give me more martial arts films I miss
that
you could always just go back to like
the back catalog right because like in
the in the 80s and 90s I feel those so
like
just go back watch all the old [__] and
then you can complain yeah
who hustle so many times yeah there's
only so many times I can watch Kung Fu
Hustle and be like oh this is goaded and
I'm like I watched that when I was like
20 or some [__] like that or no way
younger Johnny is actually still
producing some
um in China I think he's still like
producing he just did a pretty big epic
but I think he used a lot of I'm not a
big fan of China I'm not a big fan of
the martial arts with the wires I'm a
huge fan oh yeah I'm not I'm not too I
prefer more grounded martial arts yeah
because I watched like a like a GQ or
whatever it is one of those interviews
and he's trying to make like a mix of
superheroes mixed with martial arts and
I'm like yeah I'm good the martial arts
yeah because yeah like in terms of like
the martial arts genre that was a genre
I never got into as well like the whole
uh doing seven backflips in the air yeah
like Crouching Tiger Hidden Dragon hero
all that stuff even though there are
some beautiful things huh Hero's pretty
good I mean it was beautiful but I will
never take hero over something like Ip
Man or something yeah but donnian versus
Bruce Lee
Bruce Lee in hero
isn't it Jackie the chair no no no we
think of the same film I'm pretty sure
Bruce Lee is dead
sorry sorry am I to hologram of Bruce
Lee
I meant gently oh yeah sorry gently yeah
he's done again versus jelly I was like
oh my God yeah sorry what are you
talking about did you get your two Asian
martial arts actors
yeah jet leave us as Donnie I'm here
that's like an amazing fight yeah that
isn't amazing probably probably the best
fight of that uh it's like right in the
start I'd say the first dude with the
with this part the spear and it's really
yeah cinematography in that scene
insane they did that they did like 80
takes as well it's a crazy amount of
takes yeah it's insane yeah they were
dedicated I mean it's getting rarer for
you know to have these big martial arts
kind of like Superstars you need that
martial arts training hearing like what
some of these dudes are to go through
when they were starting like it was all
like Off Script there was no script they
would just do [__] and they would just
make [__] up and they would get thrown
off buildings thrown into glass like set
on fire it's like all right all right
now we're gonna throw you in a acid
Instagram oh okay all right now that you
have broken your spine in three
different positions we know exactly what
we're doing it's crazy you see some of
the Stars like Jackie Chan did and
you're like holy like that one of him
falling either police story where you
he's so there's this electrocuted yeah
all through the lights
oh my God he falls out of that light
kind of like Spanish like old style
looking Town through like the tops oh
yeah eight of them that's [__]
terrifying he he I mean the level of
unhinged uh is just crazy yeah it's so
crazy I mean there's like very few let's
say you know actors that still come in
with that mentality Steven Seagal to go
okay it comes in with the mentality
let's get it done let's make a film
actually you know I kind of miss campy
80 action films I don't know Steven
Seagal I don't miss Steven Seagal you
know what I know he he like went in his
movies when he does them now he makes
them like sign agreements saying that he
doesn't have to stand up what he films
all his scenes sitting down
yeah
let me show you let me show you like I
don't know I don't know because he's
lazy as [__] he's and there's like have
you seen the interviews where he's like
yeah when Bruce Lee was dying they
called me first not the ambulance to ask
what to do
he's such a [__] psychopath uh
Stephen Segal uh sitting down in movies
let's see what comes up I feel it was
like a there was like a thing where in
every single thing he
yeah Steven Seagal movie out for a kill
is so lazy he sits fighting
how much do you think Steven Seagal sits
in his movies
[Laughter]
wait so all of his fight scenes are
sitting down no I think in a movie there
was one where he was just sitting down
during a fight scene I think I think he
sits down in most of his movies right
that's how [__] lazy this guy he's
also just an [__] I haven't heard
great things about him yeah
do you know a movie I rewatched recently
that is not John Wick 3. uh not John
Wick three uh so I I forgot how [__]
goaded this movie was which I don't
think is actually goaded uh but it was
as enjoyable as I remember it being uh
so there's a street fighter live action
film oh my God
okay because uh Street Fighter 6
released recently yeah so I got randomly
recommended you know I've went down that
rabbit hole randomly got recommended a
clip of the live-action Street Fighter
with Jean-Claude Van Damme
holy I was like this was really good
when I was like 10. I I bet it's not as
good re-watching it as at like 33. I
rewatched it and God damn it is so [__]
it is so campy it is so cheesy but oh my
God it's such a banger that is
definitely your Nostalgia goggles toys
that movie sounds ass I don't even need
to watch it I mean it is awesome it is
us but it's the perfect amount of ass
that it flips around and just becomes so
[__] entertaining when you when you
when
taking it seriously it is one of the
most I mean I never took it seriously
have you seen it yeah of course it sucks
dude
this is this is okay let me like the
reason it's so good right
is because this is what happens when you
have the shittest script known to have
you have the [__] of script known to man
but for some reason every actor gives
110 yeah everyone every item they were
not paid enough
every actor is like fully encapsulates
and fully sells the script even though
it's the [__] script the shittest
lines of all time for some reason every
actor showed up and was just like boys
I'm giving it my a game and I'm just
like normally normally you see you see
films like this and you're like okay
obviously the actors are calling it in
no actor in Street Fighter called it in
and I'm like this is everybody else did
everyone else did and it's just such uh
it's just so much fun I don't know I
don't know why that film works I really
liked it I'm going to defend that
I I will defend the live action I wanna
I wanna hear I want to hear someone's
opinion of them watching it for the
first time with like no nostalgic
goggles right right I think that will
truly see if it actually stands up to
the test of time like you've never seen
anything about it no okay I need I need
you to watch it so we can get like a
fresh opinion sure yeah unbiased opinion
it is because I feel you and I only
enjoy it because you know it's nostalgic
for us for uh for reference it is rated
I believe 4.4 and IMDb
what's the plot uh
um what like what's the point of the
movie what are they doing M bison is
basically a terrorist trying to take
over the world so that um
girl's the main character okay yeah and
he's played by John uh yes my favorite
America
he's the best yeah that's the thing the
best American
what do they get a real American like
Arnold schweiler yeah
um yeah played by Jean-Claude Van Damme
and uh all of your favorite characters
are in it yeah uh they're certainly in
it
is like a spy or something uh yep yeah
and uh they try to take down and bison
together and then spoiler alert they do
I saw a tweet that was like every single
country in Street Fighter got like some
form of weird skewed representation of
like a stereotype you know like girls
like this American Military dude yeah I
don't know who the Russian dude is like
the big Zangief thank you yeah and then
they're like you know chunley is like
this you know like a fighter and
whatever and then they're like yeah for
Brazil it's [__] Gremlin that is just
[__] electricity and it's like how is
that representative of Brazil like what
are you trying to say about Brazilian
people they're all like [__] Street
goblins
yeah yeah like Blanca right like he's a
little [__] up but I completely forgot
he's from Brazil he's from Brazil what
the [__] they predated the Brazil memes
I just read it I was like and then it's
kind of [__] up what do you think
about it
I've been like that like every other
country got like kind of like a really
weird jarring stereotype and then they
were like Brazil [__] Gremlin [__]
Blanco Goblin ass
not even a [__] human being it's like
what the heck damn they did them dirty
yeah think about it like this kind of
[__] up